[Music]
so
this is kind of part of your core
philosophy right like breaking things
down into the
their sort of smallest components so
that you can digest them one by one
i think it's essential rich for me in my
life it's
yeah it's breaking not only breaking
say a race breaking it down from you
know a tree to tree
or rock to rock perspective but even
breaking down
[Music]
the the outcomes you know when i when i
go and race
i never feel any pressure and i never
really get nervous man
because in my mind i've broken that i've
broken that race down into two outcomes
i'm either going to break my body or i'm
going to
achieve victory or across the finish
line that simplifies it so much for me
and is it is that philosophy
advisable well i don't know i think
that's a choice
for every individual to make but for me
i look at these
races as as missions almost like
missions in my life and
i'm willing to accept the fact that i
could potentially break myself
to accomplish this mission right well
the other
option is to quit the other side yeah
but you just don't put that on the table
i don't put it on the table man and and
i'm not
by no means am i trying to sound uh
super tough or i subscribe to this
saying it's be hard when it gets hard
and in an ultra it gets hard so that's
when i like to hunker down
yeah there's this ethos out there i i
saw you
kind of speaking about this on instagram
um
out there like stay hard you got to be
hard 24 7.
you know and i think people in general
need a kick in the pants and that's a
worthy message
that i think is helpful to a lot of
people who have
gotten a little too cushy or comfortable
in their lives but
staying hard all the time is not a
sustainable lifestyle philosophy is it
it's not sustainable rich and i i really
feel like
um for me personally it's a dangerous
philosophy
because if you have
if you think as a man or a woman
that you have to be hard all the time we
said it's not sustainable so you're
gonna fall
short of that mark
and when you fall short of that mark
you're going to beat yourself up about
it
and it just causes problems i i feel
like
for me personally and it causes problems
in in
in relationships man you know when
you know when i was active duty you know
i could be out on the road or be on
deployment well
when when you come back you got to be
able to to
love your family and and love the other
people around you
and and show compassion and and emotion
and
those all those aren't components of
being hard all the time but they're
components that are necessary to living
a healthy lifestyle
what's the point otherwise right but
they're not they're not teaching that to
you in buds
no that's something that i had to learn
yeah yeah i mean they turn you into
this uh i don't want to say monster but
they turn you into
what i guess society would call an alpha
male in buds right
right so stay hard when
it's it's appropriate to be hard when
you need to be hard
have a place inside of you that you can
that you can go to
when it gets hard and you can get the
job done so all right so you're in buds
is it what you thought it would be
expected it to be yeah harder easier
i would say seal training is probably
like the one thing in life that
surpassed its reputation in terms of
difficulty in terms of difficult
identity
yeah sure and there again that's i'm
talking about the whole
the whole picture right now you know
what is the main thing that you
take away from that experience
you know there's so many things
that that we could talk about that were
born
in that experience um i'd say the one
thing that i utilize the most
right now is
the lessons that we learned that revolve
around
the i call it the power of the spoken
word
the the things that we say how the
things that we say
impact our direction in life
and the outcome of our situations
and one of the earliest times i remember
seeing seeing this work was
in first phase my best friend
came to me one day and he said
chad i don't think i'm good enough to
make it through this training anymore
and you know i had known prior to that
statement
that he had been having some thoughts of
doubt
but when he kept those thoughts within
his own
head he was able to continue from day to
day
but as soon as he came to me that that
morning
and spoke it out loud that statement he
he created that reality it became real
it crushed him man he was crushed by
that single statement
i don't think i'm good enough and it's
and shortly after he made that statement
he went
and quit and i thought you know
this guy my buddy you know he was
completely physically
capable of doing everything that we had
to do that day
and every single day until graduation
but those words crushed him man it was
like the rubicon once he
once he crossed that there's no return
once you once you give voice to whatever
it is
whatever demon is swimming around in
your head it gives it
gives it a power that you can't take
back there's there's something about
when
it's something about the spoken word man
and i think the
the written word has has similar and
equal power but
you know a lot of my stuff lessons
revolve around that spoken word and now
that's
transferred that lesson has transferred
into
ultra running and you know i've seen
that
power of the spoken word push
people beyond their
conceived limits so what do you what do
you
make of that like what is that about
like how is it
like that the spoken word can carry that
kind of power
it's you know and and i don't know
i don't know what for me
something in your a thought that's in
your head
it's just a thought it's it's not
tangible
to anyone else except for you
but when you speak something out loud
it actually becomes something real
something that can be
measured so it becomes
something that's part of this reality
that we live in and
and and i feel like that's what gives it
the pow
the power of the spoken word i feel like
that's why it's so powerful because
as a thought it's it's essentially it's
not part of this reality that we're
living in but as soon as you speak it it
becomes
real right that's where i find the power
at man
cool all right well let's end this um
with a final thought for the person
who's
who's out there who feels stuck they're
in a rut
maybe they're not happy with their job
or they're trying to get off the couch
and
move their body for the first time in a
long time like how do we how do we
cattle prod
that that that that dude or that young
lady
to get after it a little bit more come
on man
oh my god bring us home man i am not
much of a i'm ready to hire you as my
life coach
i am not much of a cattle prodder that
that's
that's the thing rich i mean like i say
i just
i'm so hesitant to give advice or to try
to tell someone what to do
i mean i i guess i could just keep it
super simple and uh and and you know
go over the things we talked about
simplify things
don't be afraid to put yourself in
adverse situations because that's where
you're going to grow as a human being
the decisions you make in times of
adversity self-inflicted or
or totally out of your control are the
things that
those decisions define who you are as a
human but don't
fear inflicting that adversity on
yourself because it's going to help you
grow as a human being
so i would say go put yourself through a
little adversity it may be
it may be only running for five minutes
to start with
it may not be running it may be
something completely different than that
yeah but don't fear it because i feel
like it's essential for us
as as humans to experience that in life
and the last thing that i would say is
if you're struggling
emotionally uh from that kind of aspect
is
take a look at your body soul and spirit
look at those three aspects of your
humanity
each as a single lane and
think about what are you doing on a
day-to-day basis to master nourish and
maintain your body
your soul and spirit and usually
that can be used as a diagnostic to see
okay i am lacking here i'm lacking
and i need to get some help with my
emotional side
my will what i want and don't want to do
do i want to get out of bed in the
morning do i not want to get out
you know that type of stuff and then the
spiritual side
you know that can be it doesn't matter
what it is it could be spending time in
nature
for me it's spending time in god's word
it could
it could be anything you know right
[Music]
well a lot of people's new year's
resolutions pivot around movement
right and that's what you're writing
about in this new book so
let's talk about movement um i'm i'm
super interested in hearing your
thoughts
that you explore in this book about
what's happening with us
psychologically and biochemically when
we move our bodies
let's start with the biochemical because
some of this is so fascinating
um can i explain the hope molecule thing
yeah i was
trust me i wrote that down like these
whole uh
these these hormones are recent the
myokines
super interesting um i know when i found
so i came across this paper i think it
was maybe a 2016 paper
where the scientists talk about this
research and they just sort of throw out
the term
hope molecules and i remember circling
it i think i like said to my husband oh
my gosh you're not going to believe
this term it encapsulates so much about
why
movement is amazing and i feel like
nobody else is using this term it's just
this one paper i'm not even sure the
scientists i've used it again but uh
let me explain what it is so this is the
idea that our muscles are like an
endocrine organ
and that when you contract your muscles
in any type of movement
they are secreting chemicals into your
bloodstream
that are really good for every system of
your body i mean they're great for your
heart health and your immune function
and
some of them can kill cancer cells you
know all the stuff we know
exercise is good for but that a big part
of these
these proteins and chemicals that are
being released by your muscles which are
called myokines
they have profound effects on the brain
so you go for a walk or a run or you
lift weights
and your muscles contract and they
secrete these proteins into your
bloodstream
they travel to your brain they cross the
blood-brain barrier
and in your brain they can act as an
antidepressant like irisin can
they can make your brain more resilient
to stress
they increase motivation they help you
learn from experience
and the only way you get these chemicals
is by using your muscles
it's like this is part of how we become
our best selves is we have to use our
muscles
and then the scientists called them hope
molecules because in this one study
they found that exercise could protect
rodents from experiencing depression and
post-traumatic stress disorder
if you severely traumatize them so this
idea that that these
molecules are giving you hope even in
very difficult times so
it's not innately human that's right
it's not innately humans
it is in other mammals it's in well it's
so i don't know how many species this
has been studied in it's like
in in this field you tend to go from
mice and rats to humans
there's like not a lot in the middle um
but it should be pointed out that
rodents are very social species and
that's one of the reasons why they're
they can be really great models for
human behavior because they look a lot
like us
in some of the very basic social and
psychological ways so
extrapolating on that idea like what do
you like what do you make of that like
what does that
mean well first of all a very practical
level it means when i
go for a walk or i exercise i will
literally say to myself
you're giving yourself an intravenous
dose of hope like i think this is how we
should frame movement
that that it's something you can choose
to do to really
powerfully influence your mental health
and your resilience and every time you
move you're doing that
i think to know that to like look at
your own muscles and be able to say
thank you legs you're tired now that was
hard work
but like legs you're you are a pharmacy
that of antidepressants and resilience
and hope
um then sort of thinking like in a more
philosophical way
again one of the things that i feel like
the anthropology and the science is
pointing to
is that movement is how your brain
knows you are alive and engaged in life
and when you move on a regular basis
your brain
basically says i guess we have to be
the best version of ourselves because
we're in this thing called life
and so you mentioned some other things
too like
when you exercise you see increased
levels of neurotransmitters
that tend to increase our willingness to
cooperate
and the pleasure we get from connecting
with others that give us hope and
courage
i mean even that lactic acid that that
metabolic byproduct
of exercise that lactic acid seems to
have an anti-anxiety and antidepressant
effect
this is a crazy stuff it's not just an
endorphin rush it's like at every level
of our biology
when we move our brain is like
i guess we we have to do this thing
called life and so you know for people
like me who've struggled with anxiety
or depression this idea that you can
convince your brain
to want to fully engage with life in a
brave way or in a hopeful way
through movement is so phenomenal
how does competition play into this
because we you know if we talk about
movement a subset of movement
is sports sports being inherently
competitive
there has to be healthy aspects oh yeah
to this
but also unhealthy aspects yeah i think
so competition is a major human
drive and there's a lot of psychological
benefits to it so
when people tell me that they love
competition like my sister is more like
this than me is one of our fundamental
differences
she loves to compete she loves to
improve she loves mastery
and i'm i just sort of i don't know that
doesn't motivate me
like at all so i think the
the really healthy positive sides of
competition
one is if you're competing as a team or
with a group
and the tremendous bonds and what you
learn from
uh cooperating in order to compete that
that that seems like that has
tremendous benefits and that even if you
look at like children
who are teenagers who are engaged in
different types of sports
it looks like there are more
psychological benefits to being
involved in team sports than individual
com competitive sports
because there can often be so much
pressure on the individual with
you know to be the best without some of
those other
social forces that come into play when
you're working with others
um and i think the other thing that's so
helpful and healthy about competition is
when
it's really more about mastery that that
you have
a sense of setting goals and moving
toward them and that they're personally
meaningful
and you you sense yourself as somebody
who can set goals that are difficult and
work toward them and meet them
at that whole chapter about overcoming
obstacles and the very definition of
hope
is to have a goal that's meaningful to
believe you have the resources
to meet it and there are steps you can
take and
i think there are forms of competitive
movement
that will really allow you to access
that whole experience of hope
all right well i want to bring the focus
back on to
new year's resolutions and i think one
thing that happens with a lot of people
is they're faced with this
decision of like oh i have this goal i
want to do this thing
do i just go whole hog all in overnight
or do i take little bites out of this
and and do it
slowly in a way that doesn't completely
you know upend my entire life
i'm mystified by people who believe
there's an answer to that question
of course it depends you must get that
question every day
and the thing is is you start where you
are
and you do what you can do and you do it
in the way that feels like the right way
to do it for you
and whichever path you choose you don't
tell yourself that's it or i failed
like you know there's some people who
will take the baby steps they get that
goal down to the tiny thing they can do
tomorrow and
feel successful and they find that they
don't actually feel successful because
they don't see the benefit of it
or it doesn't have a deep meaning to
them so you should give yourself
permission
okay you need to go harder on this
what's the version of this that
when you finally get to do it you're
going to feel like
that's a triumph and then you give
yourself as much time as you need to to
get to that point
if you feel like you want to go all in
and then you find out a month later this
is not
working the way you had intended that it
was a learning experience
i think people shouldn't believe that
there are
these tricks to behavior change
that are beyond what your intuition can
lead you to
if you are clear about what you care
about and you're willing to experiment
and not give up the first time it
doesn't go as planned right
i think that's super wise i think that
these things are all about
getting caught up in some kind of future
tripping
or tripping over you know
stories that we tell ourselves about the
past right and the truth is all we have
is what we're doing right now
and i i kind of love the way 12 step
does it it's just like
you don't have to like you don't have to
worry about whether you're going to stay
sober for 10 years like what are you
doing right now are you going to drink
is your pill
is your head going to hit the pillow
tonight are you going to drink before
you go to sleep tonight like that's all
you got to worry about right like
those tiny imperceptible things that in
the grand scheme of things seem small
but actually
are the levers that move everything yeah
i think you know one example i often
think about
um so one of the most difficult things
to do is to quit smoking
there are some people who can do it cold
turkey and i've talked to people who
they made that decision
and they just did it and for whatever
reason it worked for them it was an aha
moment
but there's research showing that if you
can delay the first cigarette of the day
by five or ten minutes that increases
your chance of of quitting
so like that seems that seems totally
possible
delay the first cigarette by five
minutes and that's something you could
choose to do tomorrow
and to know that both of those are
pathways to the same place
and you don't always know at first which
one's going to work for you but that and
there's a million
paths in the middle that look like
something else
well let's talk about what it is that
you do like let's
in your estimation like what are the
most important things that
and and again you can preface this
whatever with whatever caveats you want
but like what do you think are the most
important things that people should be
doing or looking after on a daily basis
to kind of
you know take out an insurance policy
against aging
given the current state of knowledge and
understanding that's well put
okay now i feel free to speak because i
don't endorse and i don't recommend
um i think the most important thing for
anybody
to live healthier for longer if there's
just one thing i could say
would be eat less often don't eat three
meals a day
i i literally think that that people who
recommend three meals plus snacks
trying to keep your glucose levels
always at a pretty high level
are doing the world of disservice and
i'm gonna go out on a limb to say that a
lot of nutritionists would disagree with
me
but i've been doing this for 30 years
i've seen what happens to people and
animals
when you restrict their food and it it's
all good
i mean you don't want malnutrition or
starvation of course
but putting the body in a state of want
every day
um for as long as you can do it i do it
you know like i said hopefully till late
afternoon dinner that's the easiest and
best thing you can do
other things are the high intensity
interval training or
jumping up and down with weights in a
swimming pool almost drowning that's
pretty good
right you're going back tomorrow right
yeah well i will do it again actually
now i'm i actually think i know not to
go too far into the deep end
but but honestly we now know we all have
the the power
with the scientific basis to actually
live at least 15 years longer okay so
there are actually and i i
talked about this i think on twitter
recently that there are there are five
things that
are pretty obvious and easy to do uh
that'll give you 15 years
and that's just off the top of of my
head
things like you know exercise
the fasting don't eat too much eat the
right foods try to be
plant-based uh get sleep have
social network that gives you 15 years
that's amazing
that's not even going delving deep into
my book which
takes it to another level of what the
best exercise and supplements probably
are
so that's the good news um i do list a
lot of things we could
we could talk for hours about what i do
page 304 you'll see more
i'm conscious that we have a microbiome
that is that needs to be healthy so i
make my own
special uh yogurt which i mix my
resveratrol in
um i think i'll release the recipe of
that pretty soon
in the newsletter if anyone would like
to make it so that these are the things
um on the uh sorry to enter jack but on
the
you sort of sort of said you know eating
eating plant-based predominantly
plant-based
i mean a lot of that is is um
informed by the relationship between
excessive protein intake
and that the that impact on aging
correct
well it's about from your from your
perspective in the work that you're
doing so the
so the plant-based food um i think a
little bit of meat's fine especially if
you work out you're trying to
build bulk ups of muscle but i think
that what we've learned is by studying
the sardinians and
canarwins is that those diets are the
best for for humans
and they are mostly plant-based with a
little bit of meat like fish
so why does that work okay why do we
think that works the two reasons one is
that
you don't want to overload on certain
types of amino acids which
you'll find in meat uh leucine
isoleucine valine these
turn off our body's defenses through a
pros uh pathway called
mtor um they'll probably be a nobel
prize awarded for that stuff by the way
it's big deal mtor but if you're always
eating a lot of protein
in terms of meat then you'll you'll
never really optimize your body's
defenses so i try to
eat plant-based foods but there's
another thing that that most people miss
which is the xeno-hermetic molecules
from plants
you get those you don't get those from
meat as much so what do you make of the
carnivore diet
yeah i'm on this on the other side
uh i it is an interesting phenomenon
it's good long-term just like
sort of culturally to go how did this
suddenly happen and there's a cohort of
people who are all about just
that's all they eat right this hasn't
been going on for very long
the story very much has yet to be fully
told
um but you know if somebody's listening
to this and
perhaps was flirting with the idea of
that i mean to
you know what what would be your
response to that person
all right well so i'm a scientist so
let's talk some science uh briefly
the what what you do when you activate
this
mtor pathway is you're telling your
cells in your body
that times are good you've just caught a
mammoth okay basically
and now's the time to build
your body and actually fix things uh
heal
things and grow and it turns out that
there are there are two things your body
can do
there's grow and then there's on the
other hand
the other side of the balance is to
protect
growth protect growth protect and if
you're always in this growth mode
by telling your body now is the time you
got your amino acids grow
that's great when you're young and
middle aged you'll bulk up right
you'll feel good you'll actually burn
energy more you'll
lose a bit of fat but long term
you're going to sacrifice your longevity
in my view because you're not turning on
your body's defenses which
typically are turned on when your body
senses that there's adversity there's a
need
yeah so being hungry and eating plants
are going to be telling your body times
are not as good
we've run out of mammoth meat let's
hunker down but you could
we're on our own we're on our own so
we're going to have to you know do the
heavy lifting here
it's it's basically catalyzing these
systems these biological systems to
protect the body right yeah and and in
turn promote longevity
versus oh this we've got an endless
supply of food coming in here we can
just shut everything down because we
don't have to worry about it
right think of it this way when we're
young our defenses are on hyper alert
our bodies don't get diseases you don't
find babies with alzheimer's disease
their cells know how to repair uh and
and defend against
issues by eating a lot of meat i think
what you'd
likely to be doing is accelerating that
process
towards older age so because you your
body will
uh yeah be in a growth state but you
won't be turning on your body's
defenses and actually as you get older
your defenses go down and down and down
and that's one of the main reasons that
we end up getting old
okay so you've got to get your defenses
up like you're a baby
um speaking of which i've been on on a
much healthier diet the last few years
including intermittent fasting including
the supplements that i've got written on
page 304
one of the people say oh i'm not
noticing anything after you know maybe
two weeks on the on supplement
of course you're not going to see that
i've been doing it for some of them for
10 years but what i've noticed most
recently
with my current lifestyle all of these
things combined
the biggest things that that has changed
for me is that i don't get sick
anymore that's amazing i used to be the
kind of guy that would go from one cold
to another
i haven't had a sniffle in years i can't
remember last time i had a cold and i'm
on planes people are sneezing on me
i'm shaking hands at people pretty much
all the time
so my immune system must be on hyper
alert
and why is that good if you ask a
centenarian
what about your younger years in your
50s 60s they'll say
i never got sick never got a cold my
father's like that he doesn't get colds
even
um yeah i mean the the kind of
underlying theme
in the book and in your work is this
idea that there is no
biological law that we need to age like
we just sort of accept that as a truism
but
in fact you know that's that doesn't
necessarily
hold water no no nobody
um has any reason to say that that we
have this
clock that that cannot be changed in
fact what we've learned
going back to the horvath clock is that
about 80 percent of our lifestyle
um 80 of our health in old age is due to
our lifestyle and how we live
right and only 20 is genetic and
actually that that's
done uh by studying twins who you know
some smoke some don't look different do
all this stuff
your genes are not your destiny that's
the good news
so that what that means is it's up to
you and if you want to be frail
or to be honest dead at 80 go for it we
know how to do that
do everything that that the marketing
people want you to do
eat the cake sit on your fat house and
and watch movies
that'll get you there pretty quickly
yeah but fortunately you know
in part thanks to new media like this we
can actually
all talk about what we think of the ways
to extend lifespan
and and not be frail in old age like my
father i talk about him a lot i'm very
proud of him as a beacon of hope at 80
he's still
running around like he's 25 he's got no
aches or pains
very sharp minded using all sorts of
high tech
um lifting more weights than i can
literally and
our trainer who's currently training the
two of us together
he says you know what uh i think my dad
was dead lifting
or was it a something like 180 pounds
something a lot
and he said the last 80 year old that i
trained was was learning how to
get out of a chair right yeah you uh
you posted something on instagram he's
like you know
in the in the squat machine or whatever
like just
killing it at 80. the guy's in his
second career he's had this kind of
um you know resurgence in vitality as a
result of finding
new purpose and meaning and he's also
somebody who's been on your
kind of protocol for a while at this
point and to see him in the gym at 80
like crushing it it's it's very
inspiring
well i i think most of us can achieve
that in life you know there will be
unlucky people that
of course diseases still hit us but most
of us
are wasting our our lives because we're
we're basically not not you
but most people uh don't think about
their longevity
they think oh when i'm old i'll deal
with that when it comes
but now in early and midlife is the time
to invest
because it'll pay off dividends later in
life
there's something about running and that
solitude that accompanies it that gives
you the space and the capacity to kind
of wrestle with those things and and
get clarity for yourself i mean you have
there's a monologue in the in the film
i think it's after you've left aspen and
you're in the
you're in the snow and the in the
rockies where you say you know look
running was about competition for most
of my life measuring myself against
others and
a clock but it's become
a process of um not just connecting with
other humans but a process of
self-discovery
and that's like a huge theme in in
everything that you do
and and in this beautiful movie yeah and
i think that
i think if most of us most of us that do
run
or walk or bike or pursue something with
consistency
year after year i think if we really
look at
what it's doing for us i think that a
lot of us will find the same things
right um and this is this is something
that i tell people uh
and and you know running is has been my
thing but i don't think that's
necessarily the thing for everybody i
think that knitting knitting could be
that thing
uh crochet uh you know badminton like
i i just think for me i chose this
activity
20 over 20 years ago 25 years ago and
i've stuck with it for 25 years and
and when you stick with something for
that long whether it's
it's an activity or a person you're
gonna continue to learn so much more
about that but also and more importantly
you're going to learn so much more about
yourself
and right this this thing just keeps
changing and changing and changing
and it's that consistency that allows
for that to to happen
right um so lots of people have run
across america
yeah i just had rob this guy robbie
ballinger on the show who
who did it last year he did it in like
75 days
um my friend mike posner just walked
across america but most people
that do this do it with an rv and a lot
of support
um that and that support tends to be off
camera
conveniently yeah but you you decide to
do this
unsupported and um
for a vast majority of the entire
expedition it's just you with a very
light backpack
and a tarp and a ground cloth and
a little bit of food and basically
that's it yeah
so um i mean i've been
at this sport for quite a while um i
wouldn't say that i have
a huge following but i do have people
that are paying attention to what i'm
doing
and for me personally it doesn't seem
right to
to put this project out there
in a way that i don't think is
accessible to a normal
person and by that i mean i don't think
most people
can pull together an rv
in the funds to pay for a person in gas
and food for multiple people for months
on end
conversely i do think that people a lot
of people
um ideally if you're if you're younger
and you have the physical capability
can put together the funds and the time
to uh to do it in the same way that i
did
and maybe you're not doing it it's funny
because there's a there's a little bit
of an irony in there because you're like
i'm going to do this super extreme thing
to show that how doable it is for
everybody
yeah you know and maybe not everybody
but i
i do believe um you know you've got
several
thousand people starting the appalachian
trail these days
and i think the appalachian trail is
awesome like there's no doubt about it
but like
how much are you really going to learn
about you're going to learn a lot about
yourself
and you're going to learn a lot about
trail culture but how much are you
really going to learn about
the united states in this greater
context it's it's a form of escapism
and that sometimes exactly what we need
is to escape
what's going on outside of outside of
our front door
but for me personally like i needed to
uh explore something a lot deeper than
just
myself and just uh you know the
the physical capabilities of something
like that so
um so i i set a a budget for myself i
i did a thousand dollars a month um
five thousand dollars total for the five
months wow um
i slept outside most nights uh
i'd get a hotel or a motel once
once a week or once every 10 days uh
that increased
more towards like once every couple days
towards the end as i started kind of
losing it a little bit yeah
simply needed to uh go into a room and
lock the door and turn the ac
on and and turn some mindless television
on
um but for the most part what i wanted
to do
was to to put it out there that this is
something that yeah
um people can do and that there's
alternatives to these
uh to do in the appalachian trail or or
going to europe for four months like you
can
just pack a very light backpack and and
see what's out there
and it's it's really incredible when you
uh you know
when people see that all you have
is in your backpack and
they ask you if you've got a gun you
know to protect yourself
and and like no i don't have a gun
um to you know just putting yourself out
there in a vulnerable position
the amount of warmth and generosity that
i experienced was
was something that i never could have
anticipated in a million years
people given me every last dollar from
their wallet
you know and there's the guy what's his
name jim steele
yeah yeah 80 bucks or 100 i said 180 it
was
i said 80. it was 160 right it was 160
and and he wasn't taking no for an
answer no
it was amazing it was uh and that's when
i kind of realized
um you know that people in their own way
want to uh participate in this
in this thing um a few years ago so this
is
kind of something that i think about and
uh the best way for me to
to tell this is is to talk about someone
else
running across the country and that was
pete gustalnick who did
across the country in 40
i'm going to say 44 days it could have
been a little quicker
this is in 2016 so a year before
or a few months before i did mine
he did this and he was doing 60 to 70
miles a day for 45 days and
broke the the record that had stood for
unsupported
he that was very supportive that was two
or three rvs with several people
yeah it was uh it was it was a big
effort for a lot of people and
and he he's sure to give them credit as
well yeah
um but for me personally so i
i was in wisconsin at the time and i saw
that he was going through northern
illinois and i got in my car and drove
two and a half hours
just to run with him for a few miles
because it's like
i just felt like it was seeing this
mythical creature when someone's doing
something like that
and even now to this day like now that
i've done this big journey
like i still think it's a mythical
creature it's like seeing a mountain
lion or something and
yeah yeah and so uh i think that for me
that's what it that's what it was
for kind of when i came to realize that
some people when they
they wanted to give me money or just
stop and talk it was like
you know it is something rare right
there's the one guy who
it looks like he turned his car around
when he saw you and he got out and he's
like yeah my friend's gonna freak out i
read about you like when you crossed the
state line or something like that
so there was some awareness as you were
passing through of what you were doing
totally in in certain areas i don't know
why it was in certain areas it was
oklahoma and arkansas where i received
the most amount of
generosity and warmth um and then when i
got to california ironically it was it
was nothing
it's it's interesting like that like i
think what i appreciate most is
is you know there is a there's a vein of
humility and vulnerability that that
infuses
you know this effort and the other
things that you've done and
this transamericana journey
um is almost like this
performance art piece
that is part de tocqueville part henry
david thoreau
like i'm going to light out on america
and learn about democracy
and connect with people to try to better
understand them
better understand myself and better
understand
you know what is required to unite us
and bring us together
totally you know you took your time like
the priority wasn't the running the
priority was the connection
yeah and and the funniest thing that i
encountered or the most interesting
thing that i encountered
when i went across the country is that
like i thought i would be talking
politics all the time
and it never came up it's just like
you when when you're doing something
like that when people see something like
that
they don't want to ask you what your
political views are they want to ask you
about like
what you're doing what you're seeing out
there and and
and it just becomes really incredible
that so much of this stuff just kind of
dissolves away
um and and you realize that uh
and i think i say the same thing in in
the movie coming
out uh is that i think we're i don't
think so i know so we're way more
similar than we are different yeah
it's uh i think that we're 90 similar
and 10 percent different
and that 10 difference has become
inflated
so that we think that it's 90 but it's
not right it's exploited
exactly and it's leveraged by the media
to further divide us
totally and and uh you know i i
subscribe to my own media and
a lot that's uh been brought to my
attention over the past couple years
with talk of fake news and all of these
things is is
coming to terms with that the media that
i pay attention to
is also biased and and it's not just fox
news like npr is also biased we've all
got these
biases and and you know
we like to think that we're right about
uh
our convictions but the reality is is
that uh
you know there's a million different
paths out there yeah and if you grew up
in
kansas and on a farm in kansas and
and you had that lifestyle and uh
you know there's that i i just see
their voting habits their convictions as
every bit as valid as mine and that's
probably the the biggest thing that
that i gained from from my run across
the country is
is coming to terms with that yeah
[Music]
so let's talk about beauty counter i
mean walk me through
the inspiration for this and what gave
you this idea
you know there wasn't one specific thing
but i was actually last night my friend
leela rose was in town from new york
visiting and it was leela you know leela
had watched an inconvenient truth
and became super passionate about the
environmental health movement and said
to me
you need to watch this film you are you
know you're
you're loud you're direct you are
connected and i think you should pay
attention to what's going on with the
environment and so i watched an
inconvenient truth and for whatever
reason
that movie rocked my world it was just
the first time i know it's almost
embarrassing to admit this but it was
the first time that i truly
paid attention to the fact that things
that i was doing that were doing in my
daily life that the
my very existence was doing was creating
wreaking havoc on the on the earth and
so i became
focused on the environmental health
movement and started to really make
changes in my life
over the next year or two i also
had a situation where i had a woman who
was taking care of our kids or phoebe at
the time my oldest
who was our nanny i was working
full-time running best in company
and at 31 she was diagnosed with a
non-hpv-related cervical cancer and
within 11 months she had died
and and so i was watching this young
beautiful amazing woman die in front of
me i was watching all these friends of
mine struggle with fertility issues or
giving birth to kids who had pretty
significant
health issues i looked at what was
happening in the environment i thought
like something's gone terribly awry
and maybe i needed to see something
about it and it wasn't about beauty
or beauty counter at the time it was
just how do i start to
become how do i educate myself on what's
actually going on that's there so that
can be a vocal point
right for change and there's kind of
this uh
epiphany moment when you're using
products on your kids thinking they're
because they're they have the words
natural on them or you think you're
using the right brand or whatever
and then looking at the ingredients
label and doing a little research and
realizing that
the the gap between what you're being
told or sold
and the truth is pretty fast you know i
i thought i was that i was that whole
foods shopper
i was the mom that was going to local
farm stands i was eating organic i mean
i thought i was doing all the right
things i got rid of all our plastic i
was washing my floors with water and
vinegar
and then i was looking at this and my
kids had two kids in the tub and it was
a natural foaming oatmeal body wash from
a
leading drugstore brand and i thought i
mean it looks like oatmeal it smells
like oatmeal kind of to me
and then someone told me about the
environmental working group skin deep
database and i took a look at it and i
was like holy it was like eight out
of nine for toxicity and i was
pretty outraged so that really was
another trigger point for me
that's when i started switching all of
my family's products
but the one thing that i couldn't find
for myself was just
i couldn't find any skincare cosmetics
that i wanted to use
and there just wasn't anything out there
and and the more
that i learned the more that i realized
that we had laws that were incredibly
outdated the more i realized that there
were harmful chemicals in our products i
i wanted to do something about it which
is really why i started the company
right
i consider myself to be somebody who's
fairly up to speed on
environmental issues and and certainly
i'm the first to say that
you know governmental regulatory bodies
are are
are not necessarily looking out for your
best interest but even
i was shocked when we were talking you
know you were telling me last year
um about the extent to which you know
that
the fda is just this paper tiger when it
comes to protecting people
uh on the cosmetic and and kind of skin
care fronts
yeah i mean i think that you know
someone was asking the other day why
people worry why they feel that they
feel
um safe why do people feel safe in the
united states in terms of
of the products on the shelves and i and
i was saying that in the food industry
if there are two things i think that are
different about skin care and cosmetics
and
and just for clarity purposes i know you
have a lot of men that listen
to you talk about things it's this isn't
red lipstick this is deodorant sunscreen
body
anything that we're putting on our
bodies any of those things i think that
two things are different when you
when you eat something that's really bad
for your body you typically get sick you
know
right you feel it whereas idiot direct
reaction right whereas if you're putting
on
sunscreen or body lotion you could go
your whole life and you would never
necessarily know that it was harmful to
your health and then the second thing
is i mean yes if you have an allergic
reaction but in the absence of allergic
reactions
people would just continue to put stuff
on their body they wouldn't know about
it and i think the second thing that's
different is that
the fda in the food industry has the
ability to recall product when it's
known to be harmful to health if there's
a salmonella outbreak
or whatever it is they can immediately
pull it from the shelves but what people
don't realize in the united states is
that when it comes to skin care
and cosmetics they do not have the
ability to recall product
they can suggest but they cannot take
action that is shocking
to me so play that out like there's a
pro
there's a cosmetic product or some you
know skin lotion
that's on the shelves at every store and
it's got proven toxic chemicals that
have been
established to link directly to some
kind of poor health condition
and the fda is absolutely powerless to
compel the industry to remove it
correct so there are a couple things
that are not happening with the fda
first and foremost
we are not screening chemicals for
safety before we put them into the
products that we use
also shocking yeah so less than 10 of
the 85 000 chemicals that have been
introduced into commerce have been
tested for safety and about 10
000 of those are commonly used in
personal care products so let's just say
a solid 9 000 plus have never been
tested for safety on human or
environmental health then you combine
that with
the lack of regulation where people can
claim natural pure botanical whatever
they want in
skincare and cosmetics and there's no
regulation so for example
a year or two ago there was an article
about aloe based products they tested 38
aloe based products across
departments department stores and drug
stores and they found that not a single
one of them had
one little drop of aloe in them and then
you know the third type of scenario is a
scenario and an example would be
brazilian
blowout or there's one called when hair
care where they've had over 20 000
complaints of hair loss permanent hair
loss
for children and and women and yet they
shampoo or something yeah and it's still
on the shelves and same with brazilian
blowout where the people who are
administering that hair straightening
treatment were getting incredibly sick
but they can't do anything about it
because they had over 40 formaldehyde
and think about you're heating up
formaldehyde and blowing it all over and
everyone's breathing it in
the fda can't do anything about it and
that's why at beautycounter we're so
focused on our advocacy efforts because
we need to update these
these outdated laws how did we get to
this point
you know this i mean look i i think
there are a number of things i think
first of all there was a brief moment in
time in 1938 when the federal food drugs
and cosmetic act
passed where americans were protected
but that was prior to
you know these 85 000 chemicals coming
into commerce post world war ii
and so a lot of the leading companies
that are manufacturing products a lot of
large conglomerates
started making these products when they
probably you know thought they were
totally safe
why wouldn't they have thought they were
safe and now i think that the challenge
becomes you know how do you undo this
and how do you when you're sitting with
relentless capital markets
and you know you take your share price
down you know or whatever
you you do the right thing and you take
a massive hit i think people are scared
to change and so
and and i think that we haven't updated
major federal law since 1938 i mean it's
been over 80 years so
governing law in this that that kind of
covers this entire landscape is one law
that was passed in 1938
one and a half pages of legislation that
govern an 80 billion dollar industry
that still allow for chemicals of
concern that are known to be caused
that cause cancer linked to endocrine
disruption all those things
neurotoxicity those chemicals are in our
products and the
government has not taken action on a
federal level so a big part of your
mission and why you founded this company
um is this advocacy piece of getting
these laws changed and
and part of that has been you going to
washington dc
and banging on doors to get people to
pay attention to this right there's a
new
bill that you're you're you know trying
to advocate
for um for vote but this has been going
on for a year like since
2015 or something like that so we when
we launched
you know from the very beginning i said
you know there are three things that we
need to do that are
really important we need to educate
because we knew that less than 20
of americans had any idea that there are
chemicals of concern and look i've
always said this we needed
no one needed another beauty brand i
mean i'm not even a beauty i was never
even a beauty person like i never even
it wasn't my thing but i what we needed
to create a movement for
better cleaner safer products for
everyone and
so education's always been a core
component of our business
and using commerce as an engine for
change has also been
a core component because i do think that
consumer brands can move
markets faster than legislative like
legislative reform will ever happen
on the on the advocacy side you know we
started from
right out of the gate when i was raising
capital i said to all of our investors
we're going to take this all the way to
washington you need to be comfortable
with that
and we started immediately the minute we
had any skill in
2013 we started to go out there and talk
about it and we started on the
state and federal level and now we do
this in canada as well
i didn't say this earlier but not only
have we not updated the laws since 1938
the eu
banned or restricted depending on the
chemical about 1400 ingredients well
over a decade ago
when i started beauty counter we had 11
to their 1400 and now we're up to a
whopping 30
so we had to get out there and pound the
pavement in washington we needed to let
them know that it's time to change
[Music]
the reality is we are just
the tip of biology on the earth the
microbiome is always for life
it's never against life if it appears
that the microbiome
is threatening us or killing us it's
because we have misaligned ourselves
with nature
at a large level and we need to realign
ourselves with that
and we need to start to to think about
what what it looks like to be
within our moment living in as light
beings at a high vibration
in space and time with high
consciousness
with a respect for human life with a
respect for animal life that's not
happening on the planet
you know people are right now you know
saying again oh china makes this happen
every year because they have all these
animal markets and food markets and
everything else and the reality is yes
that actually is a problem when we're
killing 60 billion animals a year for
human consumption
that's a global problem and that's not a
chinese problem that is a global problem
that we're killing 60 billion animals
but a bigger problem that those 60
billion animals are largely being held
in captivity
in these extreme really toxic you know
inhumane you know levels of management
and so
if we see viruses coming out of that
well that's
the microbiomes check on on the reality
that we live in
there are checks and balances in biology
certainly that work better than the
checks and balances in our government
and and life is going to have to be
redirected if we
oppose you know health and and ecology
on that level
really what you're getting at is
developing a healthy dose of humility
and the recursive theme and everything
that you've been talking
about comes back to having
in there being like equanimity in terms
of our relationship to the planet
whether it's our food systems whether
it's you know how we interact with each
other
we are out of whack and it's nature's
way of reminding us
that we need to reset and pay attention
and again i keep saying this but you
know i don't want to minimize what's
happening there are a lot of people who
are scared and there are many people who
are suffering and people are
dying but i think you know
if we can really connect with this
humility we have an opportunity
to embrace the opportunity to return
with a more sort of synergistic
relationship with our planet i mean
farmer's footprint is a perfect example
of that
by returning to what is natural and
cyclical
with the planet these farmers have been
able to find
new life and with that you know a new
happiness and a new lifeline for their
families
and the domino effect of that is is
profound
and if we can extrapolate on that
example to reflect back
upon our own relationship to the planet
and our behaviors and our consumer
choices
i think it can be highly instructive
going forward
at the same time many of these
things that we're talking about involve
systems that are out of
the control of the average consumer
how much impact can i really have on you
know our global
supply chain on our food system on
policy
on economics on you know what big pharma
decides to do etc
but what we can do is seize this moment
of solitude and sequestration
to really inventory and reflect on our
own behavior patterns
because the ecosystem that resides
within each of us
is just a microcosm of the macrocosm
that we're experiencing
externally right now and for me i've
been kind of
thinking about this in terms of you know
through that lens like
how am i living what in my life is not
in balance where can i live more in
alignment with
nature's cyclical rhythms where can i
um you know find more balance in my
day-to-day
routine and where am i blind or in
denial about things that i'm doing that
are perpetrating a problem that
recurs in my own life and i think
the more that we can all adopt that
practice
i think we all kind of emerge out of
this assuming that we can
emerge out of it healthy more empowered
and stronger and more
capable and humble and in a better
position
to create that world that we all
can imagine for ourselves and yet seem
so out of
grasp at the moment absolutely
that's beautiful i also you know i
want to just close with reaching out to
the
physicians and nurses and nurse
practitioners and
pas that are out there right now on the
front lines in new york and
philadelphia and all the other cities
that are starting to see the impact of
this
this situation we're in right now and um
i just want to
you know acknowledge your effort and the
fear that you're feeling
and the exhaustion you're feeling and
the
state of overwhelm that you sense and
the vulnerabilities that you're
you know so poignantly aware of right at
the moment and
i just want you to know that we so
deeply appreciate your commitment
and your efforts in this time we know
the extremity of the situation you're
in and look forward to the end of that
in the coming weeks
as as this passes over us and
in the meantime i just want to reflect
for a moment about
again redefining your role uh just like
we did with the garden
uh we need to to let go of uh maybe the
expectations that you're going to heal
everybody and you're going to save
everybody's life
and we need to really look at both sides
of the physician or our care team's
experience
on the one side we are all trained to be
technicians now we're
trained to adjust the knobs on the
ventilators we're trained to
adjust the drips on the ivs we're
trained to
read all the data and we're trained to
write all the notes and
look at all the risk factors and fill
out the insurance forms
all of that is coming to a crisis point
that's not working and that happens
every day in an icu where
all the technology at hand finally fails
and
there's nothing more we can offer and
the patient's dying
and then there's a second half to the
journey
that is the definition of that being a
physician state
or being a caretaker being a nurse is
when you set down the machinery and you
sit down with the patient and say
we've done our best we have done
everything we know how to do
and we acknowledge that you are alive
and we acknowledge that you are here
with us in this moment
and we acknowledge that you're to likely
expand to the other side of this rebirth
that we call death
and in that time with your patients
right now
i want you to know that we see the
greatest victory
right there because ultimately as
physicians
and practitioners we don't actually save
lives
we don't have that level of capacity or
responsibility
life is something much greater than
human
life is a gift and it's not your
responsibility to maintain it
it's your responsibility to show up and
and bring the highest level compassion
skill capacity that you can
but you will do your highest work when
you recognize that this miraculous life
that we
live this miraculous gift of life is
transient it is temporal
and it is our calling to be present with
that and acknowledge it and see the
beauty
in every phase of it and when you've got
a young person who's dying or an elderly
person who's dying
it's easy to get caught up in the
emotions of the loss
but we need to to get better and and
celebrate the moment of
acknowledging the gain this is a life
well lived this is a
person who is you know created in their
lifetimes the person who's loved in
their lifetime this is a person who's
really
in it for them for the big big story of
what it means to be human and this was a
soul that came in on purpose
and has lived some version of that
purpose and
we acknowledge that and so i hope that
in the same way that
the mess of a messy garden can start to
look like a victory
the mess of healthcare can be very
victorious if we recognize each other's
humanity in it and if we really embrace
the beauty
of human life and consciousness that
becomes often most poignant and most
obvious when we're about to lose it
and we let go of that human
consciousness to plug into something
much much bigger
and i i hope that you get to see
as the the veil thins with your patients
right now
i get to get to see that other side and
realize that they have no fear on the
other side of that bale
and says they're coming back and forth
out of and back into consciousness
in those last few minutes and hours and
days i hope that you get a glimpse of
the beauty on the other side and a state
of being that's free of fear
free of a sense of loss and only sees
opportunity and expansion and light
and so take take this opportunity to to
like down the expectations on yourself
and give up on a sense of failure let go
of your sense of failure
in those moments when the ventilator is
failing and the oxygen is failing the
numbers are going south
don't let that define your your success
be present with your patients right now
let let them not die
in vain let them be part of the message
that this virus is trying to teach us
let their journey be part of you
reach out to them and hold their hands
right now and
give them a sense of deep purpose in
this extreme thing that they've been
called to if they're called to pass
right now
let them know it's not in vain that
we're going to learn from this that we
are realizing
that we have taken too many steps away
from our purpose our
our real nature our real potential and
that
they are doing their highest work right
now in walking the journey
of dying in this situation uh to teach
us a deep lesson
of what it means to be connected and
disconnected and and a pathway towards
reconnection
and let them know that their highest
victory is at hand and
and that they are part of the rise of
human consciousness
and not the collapse of biology on the
planet um
that's that's what i want you to grab
right now and
um just know that i just am in
deep gratitude for your courage to keep
showing up
love you brother thank you
[Music]
first of all congratulations on the
success of the blue zones kitchen
cookbook i mean it's
you know once again there you are at the
top of the top of the best seller list
it's
it's it's pretty cool to see well i
spent years
writing deeply researched books that
were i i like to think artfully
crafted when it came to the pros and
only to discover what america really
wants is beautiful pictures and bean
recipes
that's it right uh but this is not an
ordinary
cookbook i mean this this unfolds much
like
one of your expeditions you know this is
this is a deep dive into these cultures
as much as it is about
like here's the thing you can make in
your kitchen well yeah i cringe at the
title cookbook because actually
we tried to make it more like a 250-page
national geographic
article so i i wrote the the
introductions are all
science driven the science of why these
foods are
helping these people make it to a
hundred i i think we have the best
national geographic photographer in this
genre david mclean
shot all the photos there's no studio
shots there it's all
editorial photography so and the and the
recipes uh none of them are re-copied
down i sat
on on a stool and watched these old
ladies cook
and captured the recipes and then
sent them uh here to los angeles
actually where they were
corrected in test kitchens they don't
have tablespoons and
measuring cups you said to actual people
or just
no just my observations yeah but the
thing is this is a 500 year old
food tradition that is disappearing
because in all these blue zones
uh the the american food culture is
coming
and replacing this way of eating that
has produced the statistically
longest-lived people
you know 20 year olds aren't eating like
this so i was sitting with
70 80 90 even 100 year olds watching
them cook the foods of their youth so
this is
almost a a project of anthropology yeah
as much as
you know a food book creating an
historical document
i like to think it is yeah and when you
look at these blue zones pillars
you know movement uh
plant-based plant slant diet uh
faith friendship connectivity
all of these things is are they are they
relatively
evenly balanced they're certainly
independent they're they're
interdependent with each other but
is there one that stands out you know
did you write this blue zone's kitchen
book because
the diet component of it is so important
or how do you think about how
the interplay of all of those yes to
your point
it is a mutually supporting web of
factors so
people eat wisely they move
naturally every 20 minutes because their
life is underpinned
with purpose they have a social network
that makes this easy their friends are
doing these things
and they live in environments where the
healthy choice is the easy choice
so they are definitely connected but the
most important variable there is
eating americans probably lose six years
of life expectancy eating the standard
american diet
this is at middle age by the way
overeating
say a blue zones diet which is largely
beans
whole grains greens nuts and tubers you
know
in fruits and vegetables as well um
so the problem is uh except for
a few people like you with heroic
discipline and a great
community supporting you it's very hard
for americans to go
plant-based and a whole food plant-based
by the way it's not
you know twinkies and chips uh you need
to um
it's whole whole foods plant-based diet
is the most important factor
but the only way to do that for the
decades necessary to avoid a chronic
disease
is have the right social network live in
the right place
having that sense of purpose where it's
important enough for you to be around
that you're going to make the sacrifices
every occasionally to you know not order
the hamburger
yeah also in this is is stuff about
you know portion size time of day when
to eat like
it's one of the things you noticed is
like well the size of the plates that
these people are using you know this is
different than in
america and how does that dictate long
term
how we you know so i'll spin out a
couple of the insights
captured for blue zones kitchen on how
they eat
first of all they're cooking no matter
where you go they're only using about 20
recipes
or 20 ingredients rather over and over
and over because they know how to
combine these ingredients to
create a symphonic deliciousness
um but not a not a ton of different
crazy foods or superfoods no superfoods
except for beans
beans is probably the superfood number
two they tend to consume all their food
in about an eight hour window
breakfast like a king lunch like a
prince dinner like a pauper
number three they tend to say uh say
something before the meal that marks a
punctuation between their busy life
and now we're slowing down to eat like
a prayer the adventists or the
sardinians or
harahachibu which is a confucian adage
that the okinawans say before every meal
to remind themselves
to stop eating when their stomachs are
80 full
they tend to eat with their family they
tend to not have electronics in their
kitchen
so they're not eating to their favorite
song or eating their favorite tv show
they they tend to cook at home as
opposed to
to going out these are all things that
i i would argue add to the um
ecosystem of eating that produces
long-lived people
and the core of which being this this
make knowing how to make plant-based
food taste delicious
amazing work how's kathy is she good
kathy freston
my cruciferous girlfriend who says hi
she's the vegan vixen um you know she's
been a great influence on
um you know really an early pioneer in
making
uh plant-based eating cool yeah for sure
yeah huge huge influence on
mainstreaming
what we now kind of almost take for
granted like oh vegan options pretty
much everywhere you go but like kathy
played a huge part
yeah you've got oprah to go vegan for a
while now ellen degeneres and
crossworld kitchens which i argue is one
of the best restaurants in
los angeles is all plant-based and
that would have been seen as a heresy
yeah 15 years ago well kind of a
also a big influence on you personally
like i
i think even in the time that i've known
you you've had an evolution in terms of
of your plant-based diet you know
relationship
yeah you know i've i come i've come to a
plant-based diet by observing the
the diets of the world's longest-lived
people and 95 percent of what they put
in their mouth is whole
plant-based food but she comes at it you
know sort of the animal cruelty
and i never even thought of you know
that the occasional piece of meat i ate
occasioned you know this just horrible
pain and suffering from another sentient
being
my favorite statistic she she told me
that an adult
pig the intelligence of a three-year-old
human
it spends its entire life in a cage it
can't turn around in
lives in its own feces connects with its
its young the same way we connect with
our young
wants to socialize feels pain in the
same way
uh yet lives a miserable life and has a
horrible death at the end
all in the service of you know bacon or
pork chop and it's
you know when you add that to the fact
that you know
eating a plant-based diet is probably
worth six to
eight years over eating a standard
american diet it's just so
overwhelmingly right
that um not avoiding the environmental
consideration
yeah it's the third prawn yes
[Music]
what is the right question to ask right
now
like if you're speaking to a white
person like what are the things that
they should be thinking about and how
can they contribute and participate in
this
in the most effective way you know i i
think a great question is
should be asking how did we get here
um because i think a lot i listen to a
lot of people speak as if
they have the answers again because of
this event
and recent events and the anger
that you see is not just because of
these events
this is anger that stretches back 400
years
because when as an african-american in
our community when we see something
happen
it's never just about the thing that
happened
it's typically about the history
this is another thing that's happening
so it's like it's a sub it's a natural
thing
we don't just look at arbory's situation
we don't just look at
george floyd or brianna taylor we
literally it's like it's like a file
that you just recall
the faces and names like that or i could
go back to emmett till
immediately i could do about personal
experiences yeah personal experiences
so i think a good question to ask is
how did we get here and i don't think
enough people
ask that question i think
for one one reason it's going to force
people particularly white folks to look
at this country differently
it's going to force them to talk about
white fragility
what d'angelo's talking about it it
forces them
to look at themselves
because to be american subconsciously
is to be white right and everything else
is measured against that
i mean i've had people say it in
conversations where a guy would say
yeah i was in this at this in this room
and it was a bunch of people diverse
you know and i you know those americans
were there and then he began to to list
the african-american or the black folks
hispanics
they weren't american i guess right but
he when he was saying american he was
talking about the white folks that were
there and he did this
he wasn't a bad person he was a great
guy but subconsciously he just
associated
american with white that's typically
what happens
and so to look at how we got here
is to now have to open up yourselves to
seeing this country differently
because i always ask the question when
you say america is so great what's your
definition of greatness
and when because if you're talking about
power like military might and prosperity
certainly if you're talking morally and
being a just society
you have to you have to go back and help
me understand when was that
because there's always been systemic
and legalized oppression
in this country there's never been a
decade
or never been a time in history in our
history
that it wasn't the case and so i
challenged that notion of
greatness do we have the potential to be
absolutely
and so i think how do we get here is a
great question to ask
and in addition to that also um i think
people have to this is a time of courage
a time of uh intestinal fortitude where
uh white people also have to confront
uh their ignorance uh when when we don't
know
and that's exposed that's vulnerable and
it doesn't mean this this goes beyond
race this is just human nature
right human condition if if we're not
something
if we don't know something and uh and
and our
current idea or point of view or
or answer that we thought was true uh
is shown not to be by just based on
evidence
that's a very vulnerable position to be
in okay no one likes their their
ignorance
exposed but if you look at that even
that term ignorance from just the sheer
educational uh definition ignorance is
the beginning of
of enlightenment it's it's learning you
have to you can't
learn until you confront and wrestle
through your ignorance right that's what
that's the foundation or the
fundamentals of learning
so adults have to embrace
um and the the fear and the risk of
being
vulnerable um you know when when they
what they may say out of just sheer
ignorance
uh is is proven to be untrue well it
requires a certain humility
right too and
i'm uplifted because i'm seeing a
willingness to
embrace this conversation in a way that
that i can't recall in my lifetime and
that that gives me hope
but it's juxtaposed against a climate
and a culture
that is more deeply entrenched in their
in being right
and their silos and you know the
division that we're seeing right now
it's it's sort of a war between those
two things right now
you know social media fomenting this
division across america
where people just want to yell at each
other and no one is taking a pause to
actually listen
and take stock and you know perform a
little bit of
you know forensic self-analysis that's
it but i think these events
have led us to a point where we are
seeing a certain
portion of the population doing that i'm
attempting to do that here today
and i think that's really the only path
to healing and to and to really
reconstructing society around more
equitable lines
rich i think you're totally right you
hit the nail on the head
you you have to be willing to have those
kind of conversations when you can get
uh when intelligent uh
people are are
stuck in their silos and their echo
chambers
uh and and spend more energy trying to
defend
their position then admit that this is a
multifaceted
complexed problem
that is going to take rigorous and
consistent attention to
in order to really write in order to
really solve the problem
until we're willing to to really embrace
that
then it's it's going to be an uphill
battle it's going to be hard because
we are we we feel more comfortable
when we think we're right or when we
have the upper hand
and so when you have people on all sides
digging in and you know having good
points
on every side but spending most of our
energy trying to point out where and why
the other side is
wrong as opposed to instead of being on
opposite sides of the table
coming together on one side and actually
pouring all of that energy
into the problem i think that's
that's that's the heavy lifting that has
in conversations like this
is a start but i think what what
a message we want to continue to to
really advocate
is uh after the protesting after the new
cycle
you know has died down after you know
the the shift in attention moves to
something else
uh will we have enough boots on the
ground committed
to to wrestling within the trenches to
right the wrong
that we clearly see right now yeah that
energy has to get
channeled into some kind of productive
change that
that is you know architected around
strategies and tactics to actually
you know enact the changes that are
necessary rather than just
you know sort of outrage that just
dissipates into the atmosphere
which is again why you hear
people really pointing the spotlight on
the dysfunction within the the justice
system uh and you get a lot of people
on one side saying you know that's just
those are just bad apple cops
and uh deflecting the attention on no
this is just if we look at it in terms
of a virus
this is just a flare up of of of
something that
you know is still alive on the inside
and what we're seeing is just a flare up
happening but if we don't
if we just deal with the the surface you
know
issue and not deal with the root cause
on the inside
it's just going to be a matter of time
before this little thing heals
but in months weeks years
another flare-up happens so we
definitely have to uh
to take this opportunity to now do some
some deep dive surgery
into the systemic issues that
allow this thing to exist switching
gears a little bit
another narrative that's out there
is that this problem is not for
black people to solve it's for white
people to solve
so what is the role of white america
in redressing this other than you know
that you
talked about the l's and we need to
educate people we need to appreciate the
complexity of this we need time to heal
we need
you know uh a longer conversation
that isn't bifurcated around political
lines like
how do we how does how do the white
people listening to this
wrap their heads around how they can be
a most productive
member of this you know movement i
i i think you know i i go back and forth
because
i believe that it's voices of color
that um need to lead
um because we feel it uh you know this
idea you can't lead me
someplace you've never been or you can't
give to me which you've never had 100
percent
it would just be it's preposterous to
think otherwise right so
so there's a learning from voices of
color
but i think taking the power and the
privilege
and and and being a part of helping to
reach
the white the broader white community i
think
right now that's that's with it whether
it's in government those
congressmen and women um using their
positions
to reach them family members on the
family level
reaching them in the corporate
incorporations reaching them i think
because we can't reach them
our job we can share we can put pressure
on we can protest we can
we can do all these things we can write
books but they're not going to listen to
us
so i think one way this is just one it's
not the only one this is
one one thing is i ask you know white
friends
you have to be the voice to reach the
people that we're not going to be able
to reach
on all these levels wherever your
influence is
that's that's one way because i don't
know what else we can do
i i really don't if you look at
literature
you look at music you look at
movies you look at um marches
we've done it peacefully we've done it
angrily we've kneeled we've knelt we've
fist in the air we've used our bodies
in ways that's how we didn't that's one
of the primary resources we have our
bodies
we've done everything we know to do
and we're still here not just incidents
but a culture right
i think it takes the white allies
or whatever word you want to use for
that to be the voices advocating in
solidarity
to the white community because they're
not going to listen to us necessarily
not all some will
but the masses won't listen to us
[Music]
i think beyond the the virus itself it's
really pulled the veil on
the fragility of our systems economic
and political
you know the fact that everything has
ground to a halt
and our economy is basically frozen
in time at the moment and in essentially
free fall
and we're now seeing what happens when
an economic system that's premised on
you know carrying you know large loads
of debt
and you know businesses that are overly
leveraged
you know this is potentially cataclysmic
and could send us into a depression
at the very least a moment of repression
that we don't know how long is going to
last
and it is opening up the conversation
about what a better economic system
would look like and this is something
that you spent a lot of time
thinking about you've written a book
sacred economics
so how are you thinking about this
moment in the context of
your economic thinking yeah it could go
either way
uh just like on the medical level it
could go either way toward
you know doubling down on where we've
already been going
and finally getting rid of all that
alternative and holistic stuff you know
or it could be like wow this wasn't
working
let's try something really different why
are we so vulnerable
why is our health care system so fragile
like we could go into this big
reckoning and house cleaning
and reassessment of everything all the
way down to the bottom
same thing with economics if nothing
changes if we just continue
on the path we've been on then this
crisis is accelerating a long-existing
trend
of concentration of wealth and the
destruction of small business
and the concentration of economic and
political power
in fewer and fewer hands because the
crisis
is decimating small and medium-sized
businesses
so you know the big ones can get bailed
out they can get supported by the
government it's a lot harder to do that
for your you know local movie theater or
yoga studio or whatever like people are
getting along okay without a lot of
these
small businesses some of them will
probably come back
but we're looking at massive
devastation for small businesses and the
self-employed
even you know medium-sized businesses
and everything that depends on you know
the brick and mortar world like the
local kinds of businesses so
we could see a
extension of this long-standing trend of
concentration of wealth
people talk about uh you know with the
stimulus checks and stuff a universal
basic income this could be the start of
a universal basic income
which could be a wonderful thing or it
could be a terrible thing
it could be well sorry you can't get a
job anymore
uh unless you're part of a shrinking
elite
but we'll give you your monthly pittance
as long as you do as you're told right
and you know don't misbehave and
you know wear your ankle monitor to make
sure that your
you know your electronic hall pass to
make sure you're not at some
unauthorized
unessential place et cetera et cetera
you know and
and so most people are kind of on the
dole except for a small elite
and they can't get off it because the
independent economy that's not
controlled by government and huge
corporations has been destroyed like we
could see that
or we could see analogously to
a holistic revival we could
we could take stock and say wow
we don't want to keep going down this
road
what do we do to bring economic power
back to the people to redress the
concentration of wealth
and that could go along the lines of and
this is a moment where we could
take a different path we could institute
some form of a debt jubilee
debt forgiveness student loan
forgiveness
refinancing mortgages at zero interest
there's many ways
to bail out the debtors rather than
bailing out the creditors and the banks
and the large institutions
and i hope that and this is one of the
one of the things i'd like to put you
know onto the radar
is that we don't have to go back to
normal
normal sucked normal was
like a road to hell
things were getting worse and worse for
more and more people
and not just people but for the for
ecosystems
for soil for water for the whales for
the elephants for the oceans
like we don't want to go back to normal
and now that normal has been
interrupted maybe we can make a
conscious choice
to go in a different direction that's
the the gift
and that's what makes it an initiation
yeah that's that's the gift
yeah that's yeah it is the initiation i
mean you've
you've talked about and written about
yourself being somebody who who is sort
of
you know always perceived that just
around the bend
you know something like this would be
coming and it never seemed to come and
now
here it is it's you know this this
moment in time
that is so unique and unprecedented and
yet rife with so much opportunity i mean
the argument certainly can be made that
this is the greatest
opportunity for consolidation of power
and wealth you know in our
lifetime certainly and we're seeing that
happening right now
and the large corporations are going to
get their bailouts
and there's going to be a decimation of
small businesses across the board
and if that scale tips too far in that
direction
that becomes a you know a scenario in
which
revolt in revolution becomes a potential
reality yes short of that we're also
seeing on the other side
in disha of this gift economy we're
having conversations about universal
basic income in a way we never have
we're seeing you know people on social
media just getting out their venmo and
sending money to people
and over tipping and and doing all of
these kind of
you know engaging in these beautiful
acts of of humanity
that are casting a spotlight on the
beautiful aspects
of what a different type of
system could produce that would bring us
together and cultivate that community
and
eradicate some of the separation that's
you know
like you said this is all an accelerant
of these trends and things that are
already
you know happening yes it's just being
exacerbated right now and that's
allowed us to have a heightened
level of attention and with that my hope
is that
we can take stock of that and really
sees this moment where we're forced to
stop when we're in repose
to conceptualize this better system for
all
yeah i i do see both of those things
happening
um on the one hand this
outburst of humanity
solidarity this that's what always
happens when
the confining routines of normality
waver
or dissolve rebecca solnet writes about
this so beautifully in in her book a
paradise built in hell
when when there's an earthquake you know
when there's
a flood when when there's some natural
disaster that
sweeps away the structures of society
it's not what one might expect
dog-eat-dog looting and chaos and the
strong praying on the weak
uh it's people getting together to take
care of each other
whoever has you know some a kerosene
stove they set up an outdoor kitchen and
whoever has food brings the food and
people
they start to take care of each other
this natural
altruism and community and solidarity
emerges
and you realize that it's been repressed
all the time
by our systems and ideologies of
separation but it's always
laying there waiting for its moment to
come back
and this is such a moment as soon as
normality wavers
people can act on their long repressed
impulse to live the lives that we are
in fact here to live which are not to
maximize self-interest
that is a substitute
a bribe to keep us away from the lives
that we're really here to live which are
lives
of service to life and service to beauty
and service to something meaningful to
us that's the only
meaningful life and the only full life
and
to sell that off to mortgage that to
mere
survival safety security self-protection
that is a poor bargain that we make that
leaves us
feeling that we didn't even live life
you know instead we lived the life we
were paid to live
but what about my life where i'm not
afraid
to die at least yeah maybe i have that
fear but
there's something more important so that
gets liberated in times like these
and it's also showing us
when you take something that's happening
unconsciously
and put it starkly in front of your face
by showing us the extreme of it
then the unconscious choice becomes
conscious
and that's what we're seeing it's like
okay here's
our destination here's where we were
going to be going
a world of isolation of distancing of
separation
of polarization of concentration of
wealth of
no human contact of no community like
we've been
silently helplessly unconsciously moving
toward that
as if it were an inevitability for a
long time
and now it's like the alcoholic
waking up and his spouse has left him
and
and he's in the hospital or something
like that and it's like wow
this is taking me to a bad place
and it's so it's a moment of reclaiming
our sovereignty and our collective
ability to
choose our future rather than merely
adapting
to something that we see is inevitable
and what future will we choose
it's being shown us by precisely
this humanity and solidarity that is
breaking
through the cracks in the system yeah
that it's showing us the future we could
go to
a future where we're all in this
together where we understand that
your well-being and my well-being are
connected and even the well-being of
other creatures and that health
and happiness and even real wealth
does not and cannot exist in isolation
but only in community and so we can say
yeah
enough of this trajectory of separation
now is the time
to rejoin the community of humanity and
rejoin the community of life
that's the the crossroads that we're at
right now
[Music]
taking pause and thinking how other
people might feel
you know um is is
not only one of the calls to action for
this moment
that that hopefully will go forward but
i think that that's like the work we
need to do now so
you know really think how do i make
space for
other people how do i make other people
feel comfortable
you know um again to to say in running
or something like that like how do we
create
a more just space in in
in our in our communities yeah um
i'm interested in in kind of what
unity and allyship looks like to you
like i'm you know just sitting here
thinking
i'm a white dude you know i'm privileged
i come from a certain background
we're in this moment and i really want
to be as open as possible and as
teachable as possible
i want to fully understand the breadth
and the depth of
what we're contending with right here
and i want to be an ally
and i'm very you know i find myself
feeling cautious or somewhat
paralytic around what to say and what to
do
for fear of misstepping in a culture in
which
you know a slight misstep on instagram
or in public
is met with you know what we were
talking about before and
not that i really you know care that
much about any of that i really what i
want
what i do care about is like getting
this right
i'm i'm interested in in
you know what that looks like from
somebody of your perspective
that's that's an interesting thing and i
think that's something that a lot of us
are thinking about
um and
one of the things about double
consciousness is is that
i i wasn't really thinking about
that situation you just described you
know like i don't think
um a lot of black americans that i've
been in conversation with over
over my life have been really talking
about
paralytic white guilt right yeah yeah
yeah yeah so the the the this
the wave of communications in the past
several weeks has been
really fascinating um let me make it
about me
yeah right like i was like here's the
thing like it's so funny because all the
white dudes are freaking out right now
trying to figure out what to say and
what not to say yeah and
my black friends are like relax man yeah
like
we've been waiting for you it's cool
yeah it's just
like how do i get it right i was like
we're not counting on you to get it
right don't worry like just chill out
you know
join in um yeah the whole
paralytic idea of getting it right so i
i didn't even even know you know like
when
after the the um george floyd killing
when when
you know black when
before we were really aware and it was
happening daily right you know like our
experiences and our understanding of the
moment
um was setting in so when there was like
so much like white
silence i was like oh okay cool white
white white people don't have anything
to say okay cool and it was actually
a real vacuum a real deafening silence
it was actually really incredible
because i was able to
i was able to just think about
the life of ahmad arbury brian taylor
george floyd without so much noise
you know and i was able to reach out and
connect to like other black people
in that space and just have these
emotional connections
and what were those conversations like
you know they were uncomfortable because
you know you really have to i mean like
everybody has divestment that they need
to consider so you really have to kind
of like
let go of machismo or you like
these kind of like chauvinistic ideas of
of
our own vulnerability and fragility um
i keep coming back to this idea of love
so i know that's
super obvious and basic and people
talked about it from time
but um ahmad arbury's best friend say
that it was weird
every time he would like leave from
hanging out he would say like i love you
man
and he wouldn't leave until they said it
and these are
like young brothers sitting around in
rural georgia at the car wash leaving
work
you know and like that's like a really
insane and rigorous process practice to
do
um so when i called up all these uh
brothers and told them i loved them it
was like
rigorous from mine it was it was tough
you know
um to reach out and
man for all the mistakes that i've made
and then i'm going to continue to make
as soon as i walk out this door
i just want to keep thinking about love
and
and i and i wish that
i would hope this would be a moment for
people to
[Music]
reset and reflect on what that is
you know and for all the little
microaggressions that we engage in or
all the
times that we
take around chit chat and anytime we
just you know
serve as a detractor to someone else for
no reason
all these things are adding up to this
giant feeling of
of psychic pain that you can just feel
whether you're feeling it in america's
cities
or you're feeling it in
a modern artery's killers like how
abject were these guys
that they went into like
seek and destroy mode you know what i
mean like
it it it it's it's not too early to
kind of think about the spiritual
poverty
the imaginative poverty that
racists feel you know what i mean so
if if we can kind of at least consider
what an ethic of love looks and feels
like if we can just kind of like
reset and refer back to those basic
civics that maybe
we thought we were going to pursue as we
got older
that's really what i'm thinking about
and i'm thinking about that honestly in
like a really
um corny kind of social media way like
it's okay to be
like a white ally with you know
1047 followers and like here's the list
and you're like banging on at white
people
but if then you're like going and
getting in the dms and like
detracting from someone else if you're
the purveyor of suspicion or innuendo
or you know kind of things like you got
to think
if our own white supremacy is
uninvestigated until very recently and
that's black people like black people
have a social sickness that we've
inherited from 400 years of
experience in this country so everybody
is is on the docket right now to
investigate our own internalized white
supremacy
this is our chance to see beyond
the speeches that politicians are making
this is our chance
to to think a little bit beyond what
our mainstream media is telling us and
what does it mean for us and strangely
um this opportunity has been a reset on
so many levels but it's been a reset on
like my mindfulness practice
and going back to the beginnings of that
and then just thinking about the ways in
which
a mindfulness practice helps us
just think of things more clearly you
know um
it's it's interesting you know you you
kind of think that
meditation is like about i become a guru
on a mountaintop or something like that
but i've been reading and hearing some
things lately that it's like
it's not even about this nirvana state
of an empty mind
it's actually about
more practical than that in some ways
and it's about like being able to
navigate thoughts and like see things
clearly
and i think that that's a tremendous
gift that
that is at our disposal right now to to
work through and i think
that kind of work on a personal level is
what's gonna
equip all of us to to kind of work our
way through and
that's what we're seeing in the comment
section right to take it from like a
spiritual idea down to like a super
you know absurd example but
before you might see all comments sort
of unified but now if you're seeing all
these kind of disparate voices
you're seeing like the fragmentation of
people thinking their way through it
in the past few weeks you know
in 1992 rioting was bad or why would
these people burn their own neighborhood
well in los angeles it was an update of
92 they weren't burning their own
neighborhood right it was like a
strategic
move to burn um non-black neighborhoods
the conversation that's happening with
white people about like
the difference between protesting
peaceful protesting
looting and writing that's an
interesting conversation to have instead
of just kind of like watching your tv
screen glow in the night and like kind
of like making
assumptions right on what you think it
is
[Music]
you